it really was like the [ __ ] house of
cards yeah there's a book called
partners in power which details it all
and that again is testimonies from
Arkansas State Police protecting the
Clintons prosecutors they were trying to
prosecute drug deals who ended up death
threated all kinds of crazy stuff went
on dan the prosecutor that would pop
that pretended to help Linda Ives that
was coming in to the Savior to get her
justice was lay a sense of prison for
running a drug ring Wow think his name
was Dan Harmon I'm getting confused as
to Dan's in my book was Dan Harmon as
Dan Lassiter one was the finance guy who
was laundering the cocaine money for
Clinton okay
I contributed to him and if he wanted to
launder your money if you want to be
part of that they were doing loans
through Arkansas Development Finance
Authority this is the scam they set up
according to Larry Nichols who worked
for them another insider 100 million a
month was getting laundered through ad
fur and to get a loan from outfit that
you never had to be pay back you had to
submit your application we have a check
for five or ten grand however it's a
rose law firm where Hillary clearly
Clinton was that
wow man don't forget Clinton was a
person who got a pedophile off it did so
much damage to his victim and she was
cackling about afterwards Maya weren't
there people who had there was autopsy
reports of people with like multiple
shotgun wounds to their chest okay I was
labeled a suicide yeah the medical
examiner who said the guy the boys had
laid side by side on the tracks and
there was a term there was a term
developed for this kind of an Arkansas
suicide aka a Clinton murder
all the way from the boys and the trucks
to Jeffrey Epstein okay now let's go
back to this guy Barry seal yeah so he
was the he was at literally flying this
cocaine back at the US I never answered
your question who killed him that's
right yeah so Barry seal is flying the
cocaine in and the weapons outs in
Nicaragua he's doing all kinds of shady
transactions on the side and he gets in
trouble with the DEA so what you're
seeing here is a pattern whether it's
Epstein whether it's ghilane Maxwell
over its Robert Maxwell of people
working with the intelligence agency hmm
but in so much trouble they cross a line
whereby they become a liability that's
exactly what happens with Barry seal he
gets it troubled the DEA he knows so all
this stuff about the cocaine shipments
too much information he's a liability
hmm as he gets him more trouble DEA he
starts sweating George HW Bush to help
him to go out the situation George HW
Bush does not help him what happens is a
federal judge on his case with the DEA
orders Barry seal that he's no longer
able to carry a gun orders Barry seal
that he's no longer able to have armed
bodyguards orders Barry seal to live in
a halfway house or a fixed address now
Barry seal during his work for the DEA
to try and get himself out of trouble
had snitched on Escobar and Escobar had
a contract out on him well they couldn't
catch him Barry Co said I could see a
Colombian a mile away in loot Louisiana
so the federal government knew Bush knew
take away his guns take away his own
bodyguards put him at a fixed address
the Medellin Cartel are gonna wipe him
out like that
and that's exactly what happened so who
killed him you killed him
both Wow Wow Bush took away his
protection and made him vulnerable and
the Hitmen came in and oddly enough I
just interviewed a couple of days ago I
think you got you interviewed him as
well thing yeah Jorge about this yeah
yeah and he talks about this because he
met one of the shooters did me off Barry
seal he met the hitman and Danny really
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh my gosh yeah yeah
and that's what I believe went down
that's what Barry seals son believes
went down he gave me a quote for the
book he said you know it's the only one
who's put the truth out there and the
other question oh yeah oh yeah I forgot
papa Barry seal was found dead and there
was a phone number on him and that was
the line the phone number for George HW
Bush was found on him when he was too
many whites yeah and of course the feds
come in and just take all the evidence
straight away yeah and how are you able
to uncover this because it's just been
thoroughly documented by everybody
involved in the case Terry Reid's credit
to him his book compromised well Terry
Reid Terry Meade was a straight shooter
mm-hmm and Barry knew he was a straight
shooter and he did not tell him that
there was cocaine coming back he just
told him you know patriotism communism
fighting this war Nicaragua the guard
the weapons
Terry had no idea now Barry seals dream
was to have a cia-sponsored airline like
suffer no transport but do it over
Mexico and the CIA proceeded to set that
up with Terry Reid but when Terry we'd
learned about the drug shipments he blew
the whistle and then he he had to go on
the run they criminalized him they tried
to kill him and it's all detailed in his
book compromised
I urge people to go and read it and
these are insiders these are insiders
they're not conspiracy theorists
just-just-just
price out
all right so Escobar them Colombia has a
cartel boss in each area so you got you
know Rodriguez gotcha is the boss of the
Bogota region you've got the challah
brothers Gilberto on Miguel the Cali
cartel bosses of Cali and got Pablo the
boss of midian you got the castaigne
brothers who instrument there were some
of Pablo's guys who were instrumental in
his death you got all these big
traffickers across the country that's
the point that I'm saying King the
kingpins the kingpins yeah the US come
along and you know because of drug laws
cocaine's going for what 60 grand a kilo
in the 1970s coming down and coming down
slowly into the 80s
Pablo can sauce coca paste with $60 a
kilo of Peru and Bolivian to begin in so
because of drug laws the profit margin
is astronomical and doesn't matter who
gets arrested the cocaine will always
flow now when the suffix so profitable
in the world is drugs if you're the most
powerful country in the world you're
gonna want to lock that down and that's
that's what the CIA did they said look
is our justification if the Communists
are running this and they armed
themselves with money they're gonna be
knocking on America's door its domino
theory you know all these countries in
South Central and South America fall
Mexico falls next thing they're gonna be
knocking on our door so we gotta control
this situation but at the same time
while they're profiting from it they're
fighting of what the US federal
government is fighting a war on drugs so
the CIA has got the highest level of
security power and clearance they're in
charge of running the drugs the DEA
another arm of the US federal government
is facing the war on drugs but by
fighting the war on drugs you choose you
you could arrest and you choose you can
allow it's a deal it's the ultimate way
to control the drugs market and George
HW Bush
dinner was bragging when asked about
this was bragging it's beyond the public
conception the people running the drugs
people fighting the war on drugs could
be running the drugs it's so beyond the
public's that's how he got away of it he
said it's because it's so beyond what
the public's minds will accept the
arrogance of these [ __ ] Psychopaths
Wow yeah yeah so if you're facing the
war on drugs what do you need a
boogeyman huh Pablo Escobar was the
boogeyman and all all the figures year
the median cartel were doing a lot but
all the figures that the US prosecutors
say I am embellished and exaggerated and
you know was it Baron said he was the
richest guy in the world all those years
in a row well Juan Pablo Escobar said
barons never came out and audited our
finances you know how do they make these
things up they make him about the clear
blue sky the time
Medhi ain't the term the median cartel
was made up by US federal prosecutors
right the more power make these
prosecutions more easily and give them
longer sentences it's all a construct if
the war on drugs so you arrest Pablo
such a victory we're gonna pause now
with kilos of cocaine that's what the
judge it you only posing with kilos of
cocaine gonna get more votes all about
the votes
[Laughter]